So let's look for a second at different ways
to compute probabilities for coin flips. You have a
coin that has probability P of coming up heads.
I will give you now 3 very different formulas.
Here's a single probability, here's our common [UNKNOWN] formula
and here's our Gaussian exponential. So what I want
to know from you is which one of these
formulas is best suited to compute a probability for
a single coin flip, a few coin flips, or many coin flips,
possibly even infinity coin flips as a limit value? So click exactly
three of those buttons, one each row and one each column for
the best correspondence of the formula to the case on the left